تحولت مدينه بافلو في نيويورك الى اشبه ما
يكون ساحه حرب حرب مع الطبيعه هذه المره
مع ذلك الزائر الابيض الذي اتى بكل قسوته
وشراسته هذا العام هكذا وصفت حاكمه ولايه
نيويورك الوضع في المدينه المنكوبه عشرات
الضحايا بعضهم جرف مع الثلوج واخرنا
حوصروا واعاقه الثلوج وصول طواقم الطوارئ
لانقاذهم سيارات طمرت تحت الثلوج منازل
بلا كهرباء وعائلات المحاصره حتى الحركه
مجمده ولا بوادر على الحصاري عاصفه
[موسيقى]
الطقس القادسيه ادى الى انخفاض درجات
الحراره في 48 ولايه امريكيه الى مدينه
صفر فطلق تجمده كل شيء حتى حقول وخطوط
انابيب الغاز مع عطله عند ذات الغاز
الطبيعي في الولايات المتحده فانخفضت نسبه
انتاج الغاز الذي يستخدم في التدفئه
وتوليد الكهرباء 10% بسبب تجمد الكثير من
المحطات ماذا فعل شركات الكهرباء
المواطنين الى ترشيد استهلاك الطاقه لتجنب
انقطاعات الكهرباء